- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is: be restless.
Over to you Nikesh Arora.
(cock crows)
(rap music)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- In my life I've always been restless.
I've never been able to
settle with status quo.
Every time I felt that
life was getting boring,
life was getting unexciting,
I decided to pick up and move
and do something different.
And I actually never had a plan.
So, I go speak at places, people ask me,
so did you have all this charted out.
And I've never had a plan charted out.
I still don't know what's
going to happen tomorrow.
As long as you're happy,
as long as you feel you're
making a difference,
as long as you feel that your restlessness
is getting satisfied.
Which again, is an oxymoron
because once your
restlessness gets satisfied,
you're no longer restless
and you have to be restless again.
So, I've always tried to be restless,
always tried to do something different.
I grew up in this country.
I ended up being an engineer,
decided I didn't want
to do that for too long.
Which was a bad choice, now
that I'm in Silicon Valley
I realize I should have
stuck to those guns.
But anyway, decided to
become a business person
and decided to go to
business school in the U.S.
I landed there with two suitcases
and a pair of white socks,
which I still remember fondly
but that's part of my romanticizing again.
So, from there on, I graduated
business school again.
I went to work in the financial industry.
When I was applying for jobs,
I was told that you don't
have enough finance,
so since from then I went
and got two more degrees in finance.
So, every time I felt
that I've been challenged,
I've gone and picked up my bags
and done something different.
So, I got bored in Boston,
I picked up the same two
bags and went to Germany
and decided to work in Germany
where I didn't speak a word of German,
and the average peer
group was 50 years old.
So, there are many moments in our lives
when we come to that point and realize
what would have happened if
I'd have gone the other way.
Or what if the doors had shut sooner
before you walk into the train.
And you can go back and think
about those moments in life,
but it's not about those
moments, it's about the moments
when you actually walk through the door.
- I think entrepreneurs, in
general, are pretty restless.
We are a restless bunch.
We are not satisfied with the status quo.
We want to change the way things are done.
We don't like our boss,
we don't like our job,
we don't like the industry we're in.
And instead of just
complaining, what do we do?
We make a change, we do our own thing.
We want to be the change that
we want to see in the world.
That's what we as entrpreneurs do,
and it's why I believe every major problem
in the world would be
solved, not by corporations,
not by charities, but by entrepreneurs.
I think we hold the secret
to every positive change
that is coming in a big way.
And so I think restlessness helps us
in two major ways, and
one is kind of hidden.
The first is the decision to start.
Right?
A lot of people have ideas.
A lot of people want to start a business,
not everybody does because
they're not restless enough.
They don't want it badly enough.
They're safe, they're secure.
Sure, they'd like to have more money.
Sure, they'd like to have a bigger impact.
But they have a nice job,
you're making nice money.
You have commitments and responsibilities,
and people to look after.
You can't afford to go
out and do that thing.
You're not restless enough.
Right?
You're too safe in your environment.
And so you don't ever do anything.
And that's 90% of America,
you wake up to a job that you hate.
And so, the restlessness in entrepreneurs
allows us to get started,
to pursue our vision, to build a company,
to solve a problem, to be fulfulled,
to help customers.
That's what we do.
The second part of restlessness, though,
I think is kind of like a silent killer
for a lot of entrepreneurs.
What happens in a lot of companies is
we get bored of our companies.
That's not something a
lot of people talk about
but it happens a lot.
It happens to a lot of entrepreneurs.
They get bored, they get tired.
Why did you leave that
job to start your company?
Because it was boring,
because you weren't learning,
because you weren't growing,
because you weren't having the impact
that you wanted to have.
And what ends up happening is
at the start of the company,
the start of your new business
everything is what you want to do.
You start building your vision up.
And then somewhere along the line,
you have customers and
there's expectations,
and you found the things that
will make you successful,
and so you keep doing those things, right.
You find the path to success,
keep doing that thing.
Repeat, rinse and repeat,
rinse and repeat, rinse and repeat.
Make more, right?
Go, go, go.
The challenge is for
someone who's restless
what happens when you're
just copying and pasting,
and copying and pasting,
and copying and pasting.
You get bored!
You don't want to do
the same thing all the,
that's why you left your job,
you don't want to do the
same thing over and over,
over and over and over and over again.
Ad infinitum, right?
You don't want to do that.
And not enough entrepreneurs
recognize that.
And so they end up in this spot
where they hate their business,
where they've just
bought themselves a job.
And they're saying I
want to do this anymore,
I want to go start something new,
I want to sell this business,
I want to move on to something else.
Where the real trick
to solving this problem
is constant and neverending restlessness
and improvement in your business.
Once you find what made you successful,
keep doing that, and then try to beat it.
As you evolve and change
and grow as a human being,
guess what, you have to
bring that to your business.
If you are evolving and
changing and growing,
and your business is staying the same
and doing always the same thing,
you are going to get bored.
There'll be a point where
you've grown so much
that you don't recognize
your business at all,
you don't want to be there anymore.
So, you need to be constantly
introducing restlessness
into your business.
As you grow, as you get new ideas,
as you evolve, you will need to bring that
to your business immediately
so that line doesn't get too far apart.
So that you never get
bored of your business.
My company has changed a
lot since I first started.
There's still been that passion
for helping entrepreneurs
but the execution has changed a lot.
I never thought I'd be doing YouTube.
I never wanted to write a book.
I never thought I'd be
working with big brands.
I never thought people
would offer me spots
on their board of directors.
I never thought I'd be
investing in the company.
None of this was ever part
of my plan when I started.
But if all I did was what
I was doing when I started,
I would hate my company right now.
You need to evolve your business
as you evolve yourself.
Continue to be restless.
So, the question of the
day today is, I'm curious,
what are you restless about right now?
Leave in the comments below,
super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Rick Vasquez.
Rick, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
It really, really, really
means a lot to me, man,
I appreciate the support,
I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
(rap music)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- Why do you still care enough?
You're at a point in your life
where you could go back, you
could do your month in Vegas
and Florence Henderson could
open up and you could go--
(audience laughs)
And hit a couple of balls,
and then some pinball.
Why do you still care so much?
- Well, I'm not comparing myself
to any of these people, believe me,
but you wouldn't say to Picasso,
when are you going to
put those brushes down,
get rid of the canvas, you've done it.
(audience laughs)
- Right.
- I'm an entertainer, first and foremost,
but there's art involved here.
And an artist has an obligation
to be en route, to be going somewhere.
There's a journey involved here
and you don't know where it is,
and that's the fun.
So, you're always going
to be seeking and looking
and going and trying
to challenge yourself.
So, without sitting around
thinking of that a lot,
it drives you and it keeps
you trying to be fresh,
trying to be new, trying
to call on yourself,
call on yourself a little more, you know.
- It seems like you're a man of extremes.
Like you don't just drum,
you drum on one of the
largest kits there is.
You don't just ride motorcycles,
you ride 50,000 miles--
- I'm an extremist.
- Even when you describe your
appetite for reading, too,
it seems like a voracious
appetite for reading.
Is that what got you where
you are as a drummer, even?
- I would expect that it all comes down
to a kind of restlessness.
Because when people talk
about boredom, for example,
I can honestly say I've never been bored
for a second in my life,
but I've always found
another way not to be.
Like if I have to go to a
medical appointment or something,
I bring a book with me
so that waiting is not
going to be a hardship.
In the early days of touring,
when all that dead time
was hanging on me, reading.
Portable, useful, you know,
nurturing, all that stuff.
You learn to adapt to
your own personality.
The extremes do come in there, too,
yeah, I wanted to read
every book ever written.
Drumming wise, my determination
was more important than talent early on.
I think for most things,
you do have to have
a bit of a knack,
but I had to work so hard
to learn so many things,
but I was relentless in
terms of determination.
And with traveling, when I've got a day,
I'm tempted by what's the
most excellent thing I can do.
Which might be way too far, way too long,
but I'm going to go for that
because it's the most
excellent thing I can do.
And with writing, it just seems
unstinting in the same way
because I just kind of know
when I've done my best on it.
And maybe an editor can
help make it better,
and maybe somebody else
could have written it better,
but I have a good built-in sense
of this is the best I can do.
- All I want to do is,
are good scripts.
However, they have to manifest themselves.
- [Interviewer] Have
you ever had an agenda?
- I never have.
Have you ever been in that mindset?
- I never have, I never had like a,
I'm too restless.
I don't know what I want to do,
but I know what I don't want to do.
I can answer the question like that.
I don't want to do the same type
of movie over and over again.
I wouldn't want to just be doing comedies.
I wouldn't want to just be doing
suspense movies or action movies.
I always want to mix it up.